know my problem when I I play frisbee so
I take the watch off when I play because
it's a wrist thing I'm constantly like
mute a play like like that frisbee disc
ultimate phrase ultimate frisbee yeah
so I take it off every time I play and I
know that's thousands of points that I'm
missing out on what does disc golf
versus Ultimate Frisbee different disc
golf is what it sounds like there is you
play nine or 18 holes and you're
throwing and walking up to the frisbee
no
are you there yeah get an air son so
Ultimate Frisbee is different ultimate
frisbee you can think of as kind of like
football slash basketball it's throwing
that frisbee with the left and the right
hand yes mostly one end sometimes you
throw a little offense why don't you
switch the sucker to the left hand it's
I don't know there's something about
wearing something on my wrists of like
throwing and catching that is just not
you're so serious about you want to lose
points yeah i if I really had to wear it
for a week to get oh you really playing
competitive yeah so this is all I'm
pretty sure there's all pro highlights
but you guys are Pro there is
professional Ultimate Frisbee now and
you're playing professionally and I'm
playing professional Ultimate Frisbee
whoa
this actually looks really fun yeah was
it oh there's a lot of is that you 2016
Eastern Conference Defensive Player of
the Year
damn baby marques gonna get some wood
you have big hands it probably helps in
this sport right definitely
ah this is a fun play look at this I
want Oh snatch that guy that I just
roofed scored like 15 points against the
second it's called which is a lot I just
ripped it roof to roof Tim is that
Ultimate Frisbee there's all kinds of
yeah you can say that term before a
common one is you skyed someone but
roofed I like because it's a disk and
Sabah's head yeah whatever you Moss
somebody what is that when you Moss
someone like grass like Randy Moss
Oh like Randy Moss going up for football
and his chest is that you're like you're
like head level
right that's what mossing sullen looks
like but there's other words for it so
you might route someone I can't believe
you're doing this with
your sensor on you cuz you're so serious
about it someone because yeah you're
losing so many points wow do you do any
strength and conditioning to prepare for
this yeah so the season is a couple
months long so yes I am we're in the
offseason now the season just ended so
we're just basically rebuilding I lose
like 15 times during the season so I'm
like putting that back on now you get to
like tryout season in like February or
March and then you just start yeah
getting your throws back getting your
cardio back and starting to work into it
and then the season starts I would think
that like leg strength an explosive
power like doing box jumps and things
along those lines would be huge for you
yes so there's different like sort of
like basketball or football there's
different sort of types of players you
can sort of diff there's so many things
to explain with Frisbee there's a
throwers and catchers you might call
them so handlers and receivers a lot of
shorter faster people who aren't as
explosive but are really really quick
are our handlers and they'll go around
the squirrel around and they'll have
awesome strengths and they'll be able to
throw anywhere but they won't
necessarily go downfield and try to go
score on someone because they're not as
tall or as explosive meanwhile a lot of
cutters or receivers are you can think
of sort of like a wide receiver in
football they're going downfield in
there the athlete's going and making
plays in the air and they're hard to
guard downfield but they're not
necessarily scrolling around throwing a
lot they're mostly just catching dumping
it off to another thrower and then going
for some more yards again so if you
watch a game unfold it's very fluid you
constantly switch between offense and
defense like basketball you're scoring
in an end zone and then the points over
and then you pull again to start but as
the points going on you kind of notice
like certain players are mostly doing
certain things like mostly throwing
mostly getting the disc back other
people are mostly going downfield
threatening deep there's a lot of
terminology how'd you get involved in
this the high school I went to Columbia
High School invented this sport in 1968
Wow I had a very competitive team for
the years that I was there and I mean
friends on the team started playing I
play for the JV team for the first two
years and then I played for the varsity
team my second two years so it was
pretty serious program and we played
against other high schools around the
country we traveled we flew whoa way
against we had rivals in Massachusetts
and Connecticut and all these other
schools and then we had the big Eastern
Championship at the end of the high
school season that was that's what we
all played for we went 11 straight state
championships the two years that I
played that's incredible yeah I did not
know that this was even a thing
yeah there's a rich history to it yeah
58 yeah 50th anniversary this year that
is so crazy
I would never guess we said one was
Ultimate Frisbee invented I was had like
a couple months ago yeah yeah so the pro
league just is less than ten years old
so there's always been this sort of Club
you think of club soccer like area teams
there's always been that so I've played
for the New Jersey Garden State Club
team for much longer than I play for any
pro teams and that's generally what
players take the most seriously the club
championships were this past weekend the
New York area team beat the San
Francisco area team to win nationals
like that's generally what people care
the most about but it's not very
spectator friendly so what we've sort of
created is the ADL is the American
ultimate disc league it's a pro version
of frisbee it's mainly the same sport
but a little bigger field and a little
bit faster play just because they've
shortened the stoppages and have
referees and everything now and there's
selling tickets and selling merch and
jerseys and and like broadcasting games
and have a pro championship at the end
of the year so that's that's been like a
whole new thing for frisbee players to
pay attention to and I've I've played
for a pro team as well as past couple
years and it's been pretty fun